alors pierre et jean michel vous avez
pas mal de choses en commun finalement
tous les deux en dehors d'une image déjà
oui oui ça s'arrange bien dire ouais
t'as vous avez d'abord alors le père
absent
les 100 ans comme un tir que vous bon là
dit votre père est parti aux états unis
vous aviez cinq ans pierre si
malheureusement encore plus triste
artillerie il est parti et rien n'a pas
cédé j'en profite pour dire bonjour à
mon père si nous regarde
oui parce que tv5 effectivement il ya 80
pays qui regarde cette démission donc je
le salue bon voilà à tout hasard
à tout hasard sais pas peut-être qu'il
va vous appeler et donc comme nous il
faudrait que ça passe au paradis mais
c'est déjà une chose en commun c'est
cette absence de père vous effectivement
il est décédé quand louis n'en fallait
pas tant par les messages de 105 ans
mais on parlait de nos mers plus tôt
l'ajustement oui tous les deux élevés
par vos merdes
malheureusement est donc très proche
tous les deux de vos mères aussi
finalement et réciproquement sont très
proches de nous quoi faire alors
beaucoup de points communs donc le père
absent élevés par des mères est aussi
vous avez choisi tous les deux des
femmes femmes vous charlotte vous
véronique sanson ça aussi c'est quelque
chose qui vous rapproche vous ai déjà
parlé ça n'a pas encore parlé non plus
si on a beaucoup bossé sans parler de
financer une éminence et une âme titre
et 9,1 ouais il ya des choses qu'on n'en
a pas besoin de se dire en fait
finalement c'est vous qui nous le dit et
on va sa part et certainement après
l'émission semble après projet de
travailler ça me rappelle un peu comme
quand j'ai rencontré murray leur vin on
s'est rencontrés un soir on s'est pas
parlé on savait qu'on se ressembler et
le lendemain on a écrit ensemble et
jean-michel je lui ai dit un soir j'ai
vu un blaireau en boîte une des rares
fois où j'allais en boîte de nuit où il
était il ya un type qui a dit à la femme
quitte à côté moi toi je te flash de
l'homme et je vais dire à jean-michel
qui dit lui prend tout jean-michel si
vous faites tomber une fourchette de
tarifs et pro fait le
tiens c'est comme si un mort et me dit
ça serait facile à trois ans une écoute
si je te fais une musique est ce que tu
me fais les paroles
trois ans plus tard et me dit écoute
j'ai la musique vous l'a fait écouter je
suis dit rechercher les paroles
j'arrivais une fois un coup pour rien ce
que j'étais arrivé j'avais un peu trop
bu il a enregistré bon faire passer
c'est pas beaucoup dormi mais voilà
c'est pas tant ce n'était pas la bonne
la première fois était pas la bonne foi
et pendant celle de mireille dumas
j'aime dit qu'est ce qu'est ce qui
serait originales de films et je dis bah
voila je suis content je vais faire les
paroles pour demain je fais les paroles
s'il ya jean michel di bacco et on a
filmé tout d'un coup ça fait dans
l'urgence comme beaucoup de choses que
je fais marcher ça c'est maintenant tout
casser c'est une récréation c'est non
c'est ça c'est pas un coup c'est une
récréation
alors on se prend pas au sérieux assez
pour le faire et mais je pense que c'est
un autre comique non plus récents un
truc drôle mais je pas marcher sur les
plates-bandes de lagaf quoi sont venus
sans ironie confirmé non mais je pense
pas aux idées voilà quoi je suis
vachement cher mois d'août une ancienne
chanson pas si ça marche on veut dire on
dit on va faire les 24 heures de du mec
en question qu'il s'est pris des râteaux
toute la soirée
il rentre chez lui ses deuxièmes il
apparaît dans le conseil il passe la
nuit
a essayé de se suicider mais il veut pas
avoir mal donc
ces différentes de suicide mais sans
douleur et ça marche pas non plus etc
c'est bien jean michel je vais vous
faire à tous les deux une interview nul
mais avant de passer l'interview je
voudrais que vous disiez un mot de votre
combat pour les homosexuels égyptien
puisque vous avez lancé une pétition
ouais raconter ce qui se passe en deux
mots et 18 sur le manche oui c'est pas
de la fiction c'est un pitch qui élit à
la réalité malheureusement pas très
brièvement il ya tout le monde je pense
a dû voir ça à la télévision il y à un
certain nombre de jeunes égyptiens qui
ont été victimes d'une rafle en mai
dernier au caire devant une boîte
s'appelle de queen boat qui s'apparente
plus d'ailleurs que je connais bien
parce que je suis allé souvent au caire
s'apparente plus au jardin
d'acclimatation plutôt qu'aux queen de
paris qu'on connaît et sait ces jeunes
gens se sont fait donc prendre par la
police et le 14 novembre dernier en 2001
14 novembre 2001 ils ont été 23 d'entre
eux ont été condamnés à des peines
allant jusqu'à cinq ans de prison sans
possibilité d'appel pour certains avec
des peines de travaux forcés en
l'absence de leurs avocats ont leur
famille pour soupçon d'homosexualité et
donc effectivement il ya un certain
nombre d'associations gaies et pas
seulement d'ailleurs qui font un travail
formidable à travers le monde pour
essayer de faire d'eux de faire sortir
ces gens et j'ai eu
j'ai eu le réflexe en voyant était en
voyant ces types cagoulés partant dans
leurs prisons sur des camions plateaux
et des grillages de cabane à la fin et
qu'on nous qui disparaissent donc
pendant pendant cinq ans de faire
quelque chose en fonction du fait que
effectivement moi j'suis pas
pétitionnaires mais c'est un pays que je
connais bien que j'aime bien
j'ai eu beaucoup de d'appel de
d'artistes d'intellectuels copains en
egypte qui m'ont dit nous on peut pas
faire grand chose mais il faudra
absolument que vous vous essayez de
faire quelque chose de l'extérieur
d'egypte parce que nous vis-à-vis
vis-à-vis de nous et nos familles on
risque
beaucoup beaucoup et au fond c'est ce
pays qui est finalement notre le berceau
de notre civilisation le berceau de tous
les mois ce qui veut dire services it a
été un pays très tolérant l'époque
banderilles avant la nationalisation
alexandrie c'est une ville cosmopolite
tolérant youssef chahine d'un seul coup
7,7 cette mesure qui est plutôt
moyenâgeuse qui complètement
obscurantistes au fond fait qu'on ne
peut pas nous laisser un pays qu'on aime
se refermer sur lui-même surtout en ce
moment avec ce qui se passe dans cette
région et que effectivement j'ai donc
pris l'initiative de faire une pétition
sous la forme d'une lettre ouverte au
président moubarak pour lui demander une
chose simple parce qu'il ya tellement de
gens qui souffrent cette région du monde
sans qu'on puisse faire grand chose là
c'est très facile il suffit qu'ils qui
signe au bas d'un papier et qui trouve
le mec qui a la clé et hugo laporte et
il ya 23 types qui peuvent ça comme un
matin je pense que cette je pense que
pour que cette décision ait lieu en
egypte ils ont besoin que la communauté
internationale se réveille c'est ce que
vous faites tous les jours avec toutes
les semaines avec michaël blanc on
essaie le problème de genre de choses
c'est qu'on est tous scandalisés quand
les choses se font et puis finalement on
oublie ils n oublient pas ce qu'on va
nous vit on arrête on enlève chose et ce
qui est difficile c'est de continuer et
moi j'ai décidé de continuer soissons
quoi qu'il arrive si ça marche pas je
dirais ok revoir moubarak et lui rouler
une pelle dans sa déjà dessins d'époque
distillera libéré